Okay.
So we have the promise of the knowledge of everything,
at least everything within a certain category.
And we saw how we could see quantized energy last time and structure and
structure related to dynamics,
how,
how nuclei vibrate and how it's different for a,
for a heavier Adams.
Uh,
today we're going to look again at a different kind of dynamics and also at
bonding.
So in the one dimensional world,
this is the payoff.
We have to go to the three dimensional world.
Okay.
So you did problem sets for today and you are now familiar with things like
this.
Uh,
what do you know about the blue curve and the red curve here?
Anybody got a suggestion of what to do or what they tell you about what the true
solution is?
Angela
can't hear very well.
Yeah,
the true solution should be between them there,
the red one is,
is too hot and a blue one is too cold,
right?
So they'll be in between them.
There'll be one that'll just come back down to the baseline for Hooke's law.
Now,
the problem is that this isn't Hooke's law because I didn't show you the whole
picture.
It's in fact the double minimum,
right?
And those are both true solutions.
So the,
the the correct single minimum energy would lie between those two,
but for the double minimum,
there's one,
there's a solution that's lower in energy and the solution that's higher in
energy.
Now,
what would happen if we moved the wells further apart here,
you see the separation to the two wells is 0.6 songs,
drums.
Suppose we moved that apart to be,
uh,
1.3 OnX drums.
Right?
Now we have blue and red solutions,
but now you notice the,
it's the blue solution or the red solution.
They're the same in the left and they're both the same as the single minimum.
So if you get the wells far enough apart,
why they look like single men about with respect to their wave function.
Okay?
Now,
closer wells,
if we moved the wells closer together,
we get a lower minimum energy than for the single well solution.
Okay?
And we got a higher energy for the next higher one.
But they both look like the single men that they both started when the wells
were far apart looking like the single minimum solution,
one with no nodes,
one with one note.
When the wells were far apart,
they had the same energy as the single minimum.
But when the wells come together,
the one with no,
no nodes has less curvature,
less kinetic energy in his lower energy than the single minimum.
And the other one has one node more curvature that the single minimum and a
higher energy that is to say there's a splitting between the energy of these
too.
If the wells are far apart,
they are the same as the single minimum,
both of them,
the no,
no nodes and the one node solution or the same as the single minimum.
But if you bring them together,
the nodes is lower in energy and the,
and the one note is higher in energy.
So the energy is split about the original single minimum structure.
Now that's really important because that's what makes bonds,
right?
So if we have,
uh,
two Adams or one dimensional,
wells far apart,
say a and B,
right?
And we get a solution in a,
and a solution in B,
and if we want the solution for the whole thing,
we just put them together that way,
right?
No nodes or we could flip be upside down,
multiply it by minus one,
add them together then,
and we get one node,
but they have the same energy as the single ones would do,
right?
But if we bring them together,
the energy gets lower,
less curvature.
Right?
And that consists or gives rise to a stabilization of the particle.
The particle is more stable when the wells are closer together,
right?
What would you call that?
That's a bond.
The energy is lower when they're close together.
So that holds a and B together because the energy of the particle is lower when
the wells are close together.
So that's bonding and part and parcel of this.
The flip side of this is that you have this wave function,
which is higher,
what will we call that
antibody?
So you get combination of bonding and an anti-bonding combination because the
kinetic energy changes.
When the wells come closer together,
you get one that's less curved,
one that's more curved.
Okay,
now that's bonding.
How about dynamics?
Well,
I suppose we have this double minimum and suppose we put a particle in and stop
it there so it has zero.
That's our zero of energy.
And then we're going to let it go.
What will it do if it's classical,
it'll roll back and forth,
right?
Bingo.
Let it go.
Roll across to the same height and roll back again and then roll across again to
the same height
with no friction.
That goes on forever,
right?
But here's what happens.
Special in real quantum mechanical systems.
Oops,
that went too far
and now it's going to roll back and forth in the right.
But every once in awhile it goes across from one well to the other.
Now this is called tunneling for obvious reasons,
right?
But the word tunneling I hate,
it's one of my pet peeves.
It's misleading and mischievous because it suggests there's something weird
about the potential energy,
right?
That you can tunnel through and have a potential energy lower than is than you
would have guessed from the potential energy curve.
But that's not right.
What happens is when it's in the middle,
you have negative kinetic energy,
you have the potential energy that the curve shows,
but the kinetic energy is negative.
The potential energy can be higher than the total.
And this happens in every bonded wave function as you saw in your problem set
that the waves always go out into that forbidden region of negative kinetic
energy where they curve away from the baseline.
So there is the forbidden region out to the left,
to the right and also in the middle for that energy.
Right?
And what really happens is that you go to negative kinetic energy and high
positive energy to get over that Hump and then you get across to the other side.
Now how often does that happen?
It turns out that the time to get from one well to the other,
which I won't be able to prove to you because it requires time dependent quantum
mechanics and we're talking about time independent quantum mechanics.
But let me just tell you that the answer is if you know the energy difference
between the blue and the red,
that the rate of getting across is five times 10 to the minus 14th seconds
divided by whatever that energy is expressed in kilocalories per mole.
Right?
This is just an assertion and it's based on time dependent quantum mechanics.
It's true,
but I'm not telling you why.
So he won't be satisfied,
I hope.
Okay,
so the energy difference here is 1.4 kilocalories from all.
So how rapidly does a particle then get from bill if it started out in the left,
how long do you have to wait on average until it's in the right one,
you have to wait five times 10 to the minus 14th divided by 1.4 which means
about four times 10 to the minus 14th seconds it takes to quote tunnel,
although it really doesn't bore through,
it goes over with negative kinetic energy.
Okay?
So there's something else about dynamics and we're hoping soon to get to
reactivity will come after the exam.
After we talk about atoms and molecules.
So now it looks like we're in a pretty powerful position,
at least with respect to one dimension.
Because with this and program,
we can find satisfactory wave functions for any complicated potential.
We can make it anything we look like and just follow the recipe.
Find out allowed,
uh,
allowed energies,
shapes of wave functions,
probability density,
uh,
rates of tunneling,
all this kinds of stuff.
And we can rank all the wave functions by their energy or their curvature,
the number of nodes they have.
Uh,
here's,
here's a,
a unsatisfactory wave function.
What do you notice that's bad about it?
Is The show that you've learned something?
Yeah,
start at the baseline.
It doesn't start at the baseline on the left.
How about on the right?
Does it look okay on the right
Lucas?
Odd Process,
the baseline in the forbidden region,
if it crosses the base line while curving away,
it's bound to go to negative infinity or positive infinity that crosses in the
other direction.
Right?
And on the,
on the,
uh,
on the left,
because it didn't get to the baseline when it became flat,
it's going to keep curving and go up to infinity.
So you've got,
you've internalized a lot of this stuff now.
Congratulations on doing well on the problem set.
Okay,
so that was a bad one.
so it looks like we're in pretty good shape.
We even can handle multiple minima and understand tunneling and so on.
The unfortunate thing is this curve tracing recipe doesn't work if you have more
dimensions.
Remember,
the reason it would work is if you knew the potential and the kinetic energy
potential in the total energy,
then you knew the kinetic energy and you could assign it to curvature,
right?
But if you have two dimensions,
then there are two different curvatures you could divide.
You could assign it to it.
You don't know how much to put in each of them.
So it's no longer such a clear cut problem if you have more dimensions,
especially three n dimensions.
So when there are many curvatures,
it's not clear how to partition that kinetic energy.
But Schrodinger had no trouble.
These are the,
the shooting or equation is what's called a differential equation.
It involves derivatives,
right?
And you haven't,
how many people have had differential equations
and maybe a fifth w I guess,
or fewer,
right?
So the rest of you are feeling,
Gee,
I wish I knew differential equations cause then I could do this,
but shredding hurt.
But you don't have to because people already have done it.
You don't have to develop this from ground zero.
Right.
And Schrodinger didn't solve the differential equations either,
right?
He knew what the solutions were because people had been study on them forever.
And the reason they studied it with because of studying acoustic waves and light
also,
and Claude ne is the guy who originated this.
And here we have the book,
uh,
by Claude knee called acoustics.
I got it out of the live business.
In fact,
the,
uh,
new,
unchanged addition from 1830,
the original additional with something like,
uh,
18 five or something like that actually will see it here.
I think
there is Claude knee,
Eric's Florence Friedrich Claude knee.
And there's,
this is the title page of that book.
Acoustics of the original one was 18 three RS is 1830.
Okay.
Now what he did was take plates of different,
or he also did violin strings and Tiffany heads and things like that.
He was interested in all kinds of acoustics so that the particular experiment
were interested in was he would take a plate and suspended in the middle and
touch it in different places while he was blowing it with a violin bow to make
it vibrate.
Okay.
So you vote in different places and he'd put sand on the surface of this thing
to see what shit,
what patterns would be formed when the thing vibrated,
you know,
this is why violins have the shape they have is so the bell vibrate in certain,
in certain ways,
when the,
when you make,
when your boat or make the vibrate and the sand collects where the plate isn't
vibrating.
Cause when it's vibrating it shakes it away.
So you,
uh,
you get a picture of the pattern of vibration.
Now we're good.
I'm going to try to show this to you.
Uh,
but yeah.
Hey,
it might not work.
And just in case I can go to the web.
So what we have here is a,
I can't play a violin,
but as you know,
I can play a bell.
In fact,
I can play a bell in several ways.
Not all.
I can do it this way too.
Oops.
Well Shit.
So
that's not a very pleasing sound.
Why?
Why is it,
what's,
I'm not very good at playing the bell.
Yes.
Why does dry ice maker bell ring?
This was discovered in London by an ice cream vendor who had a bell on his,
on his cart.
And he asked the physics teacher,
a woman in,
in London why his bell rang when the dry ice from his ice cream hit it.
Yeah.
So you,
when,
when you,
when you touch metal like that,
it,
it uh,
gives heat to the dry ice,
which causes it to give off a pressure of gas.
But what it gives off,
the pressure on the metal moves away,
then it's not,
then he's not being transferred so it stops.
So you get rapid pulses of co two,
which make the thing ring.
But depending on how you touch it,
you get noise because there are many different patterns of vibration at
different frequencies that are being generated.
If I could do it just right,
I would generate just one pure tone and then you'd say,
what a great player of bells he is.
Okay.
Now I'm going to try this and I may fail in the same way to do an experiment
like Claude needs,
but instead of using a violin bow,
a,
I'm going to put sand on here.
Instead of using a violin bow,
I'm going to use this piece of dry ice.
Let's see.
Okay,
and I have to,
if I just touch it,
it won't do anything because I'll be touching sand and I won't get heat
transfer,
so I have to brush a little bit together.
Clean part of the brass,
and then let's see what happens here.
No,
I'm doing the same thing I did with the bell,
right?
It just noise,
but let me try some place else here.
This is an empirical science.
Okay.
All right.
Let's try some
spread some around here.
[inaudible]
if you're lucky.
This is really great.
I
hear that pure one,
maybe it's not sharp enough.
We don't want to spend too much time doing this.
I want to try one more and then we're gonna.
You can go to the website and see a much better one.
One side played.
Just the lost chord,
you know,
are really beautiful tone and it's on,
you can see it on the web.
I'm trying to find where and how hard to touch so that I get a really pure tone.
Well,
you're can get patterns that way.
Okay.
You can get much prettier patterns and pretty or tones than I'm able to coax out
of the thing right now and you can look at it on the web to see it.
Uh,
okay.
Turn that off.
Oops.
Wrong one.
Uh,
okay.
That has to cool down,
but I'll put the lecture over there temporarily.
Uh,
yeah.
There we go.
Okay.
Once this cools down,
we'll get back there.
Sorry.
Okay.
So these are some crude clot clot and the figures that I've made in the past
three rains,
uh,
two rings with a line through the middle vertically.
Uh,
that's the one we just made.
Now I think,
isn't it?
Isn't it the same number?
A ring in three diameters and there's a circle in four diameters that I actually
made that in class last year.
Okay.
These are ones that Claude needed did back in the late 18th century.
Taken from that book,
right?
And here,
the first ones are just diameters.
And the next ones are rings together with a certain number of diameters are two
or more rings.
Now let's see what that picture means.
Uh,
below you'll see a vertical diameter and two rings on top.
You see color coded as to whether the plane at an instant of vibration,
whether it's toward you or away from you,
is it's vibrating.
That's the pattern of it.
Cause those lines don't move.
But either side of a line,
one side moves up,
the other side moves down.
Okay?
Or You could look at it this way.
The,
the dotted patterns,
the circles and the line.
Don't move as the rest of the thing deforms.
This would be like a drum head on a Timpani.
Got The idea.
So that's the pattern of,
of a,
a motion.
Now,
uh,
Claude knee was interested in,
in sound,
right?
So he found what pitch each of these different patterns corresponded to.
So this table shows the number of diameter that are nodes,
the number of circular nodes and what pitching corresponds to.
And the,
the little lines make me that's a little sharper,
a little flat,
something like that.
For example,
the one with two diameters and no rings is that pitch,
see out the idea.
So then he tried to figure out if there's a mathematical relationship among
these things.
He,
those were 47 patterns that he observed there.
So here he says the pitch relationships agree approximately with the squares of
the following numbers.
So how many diameters,
how many circles.
And what do you see is,
is if the frequency is roughly the number of diameter diameter nodes plus twice
the number of circular nodes squared.
This is his empirical observation.
So for example,
you could have two diameters or one circle.
Both would give the number two,
which you then,
uh,
which you then square,
right,
to get something proportional to the frequency,
right?
So there are two different ways to get the same pitch,
okay?
That's what's crucial.
Either rings or lines or you can have a combination of rings in lines.
Uh,
so for higher frequencies you can get more and more combinations that give the
same pitch.
For example,
the number eight,
you can have four circles,
three circles and two lines,
two circles and four lines of circle in six lines or eight lines.
All of them give the number eight and all give the same pitch at least
approximately.
Okay?
So this is what he,
but the lesson we want to take is that there are different ways of getting the
same frequency by combinations of these nodes.
Okay?
Now,
uh,
Claude,
he didn't solve his problem mathematically about how plates or strings or
whatever vibrate,
but there were great mathematicians working on this like Bernoulli law garage
Euler,
who not only made a,
uh,
Communist,
Germany stamp.
He also made a Swiss 10 frank note,
okay?
Okay.
So the size for one electron atoms.
Now we're going from one dimension into three dimensions for a real Adam
electron in an atom.
So for one electron atom,
they're going to be three variables,
x,
y,
z.
For the electron and the solutions.
The waves were going to get our involve what are called spherical harmonics and
are three d analogs of Claude knees,
two d figures.
These mathematicians could work in three dimensions as well as to,
okay,
so a three dimensional h atom wave function,
sy,
uh,
is,
could be written as a product of three functions at our function,
a theta function at a fee function.
And these were available from other old time mathematicians.
Uh,
the,
our function is called the associated Laguerre function and his name for Ed Mole
Laoghaire and the a theta function is called the normalized associated Lashondra
polynomial.
After Adrienne Marvey Lashondra okay,
now here are the solutions.
Schrodinger didn't find these.
He just looked him up.
These guys had already done it from acoustics for three dimensional things
vibrating,
right?
So it was,
so here's a table that you could use the shade and same way Schrodinger would
have used it to find out what wave functions for electrons in one electron atoms
actually look like you.
And all your books,
you've seen pictures of these things,
but you've never seen.
My guess is you've never seen the real thing.
And you should wonder,
are these pictures that people have shown me,
right?
I'm going to get this center projector on again if I can.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now how,
how do you understand this looks pretty complicated.
This table in a sense it is,
but if you look at it the right way,
it's really pretty simple.
It relates to the position of an electron shown on the right there relative to
the nucleus and the cell.
There's only one electron.
It's a one electron atom.
Otherwise we have more dimensions,
right?
And,
and,
but the nucleus could have any charge you want it to.
So it's a one electron,
Adam,
of any nuclear charge.
And we have the coordinates x,
Y,Z ,
and we have a,
a potential,
uh,
with the potential.
What is the,
what's the potential law that's given to us?
Whose law?
Cool.
Ohms law.
So what's one over r squared and how do you write r squared?
R squared is x squared plus y squared plus [inaudible] squared.
Right?
Everybody know that?
Good nod.
Yes.
Good.
Okay.
We're on the same page here.
But that's pretty complicated function,
right?
So the equations that involve that are going to be really,
really complicated.
But there's a clever way to get around this.
Do you know what that way is?
What's the clever way of getting around this?
The clever way of getting around it is to change that.
The coordinates,
the system that you're using to one that's more natural for the problem.
And the one that's natural for the problem is Sperry or po spherical polar
coordinates.
So the three dimensions are,
are the distance and theta.
The angled down from the Z axis and fee the angle rotated around from the x
axis.
Well,
you can define it any way you want to.
This is the way it's defined in for these purposes.
Okay?
Now,
uh,
so that simplifies the expression for potential enormously.
Instead of being one over the square root of x squared plus y squared overseas
square,
it's one over r or some constant over are.
Okay.
And what that means is,
and this is the mathematical,
a payoff,
that the wave function can be written as a product of three functions,
each of which is the function of only one variable.
Instead of having x squared,
y squared,
z squared,
all mixed together in this complicated function,
you have a function only of our,
a function only of theta and a function only of fee,
and you multiply them together and you get the solution to the Schrodinger
equation for one electron atom.
Now that,
uh,
that this table gives you those functions,
the,
our function,
the fate of function of the fee function.
It's like a restaurant where you get to choose one from column a,
one from column B,
one from Column C,
right?
Here's your appetizer main course and your dessert,
So you choose one of these,
one of these,
multiply them together and you have the true function right now they look very,
very complicated.
You can't choose any combination you want to,
once you've chosen one,
once you've chosen your appetizer,
you can only have certain main courses.
And once you've chosen that,
you can only have certain desserts to get solutions,
right?
This is what these mathematicians that all figured out.
Okay.
And uh,
so how do we go about,
uh,
doing it?
Well,
we can name the PSI.
We're going to get by a nickname like one s or two p x or something like that.
But you can also name it by the numbers that name these individual functions.
And those are in l and,
m,
which I think you've encountered before probably.
So let's,
uh,
let's make a try at it.
No,
we'll actually noticed something about the complicated form of the functions
first.
Every one of them has z over a zero to the three halves.
Power.
Zhi is the nuclear charge a zero as a unit of length of about half an angst from
about,
okay,
so to the three halves power,
that's pretty weird.
But remember what you're going to do with the wave function.
What do you do with wave functions other than find energy?
Yep.
Probability density.
And what do you do to do that same square?
You're square.
So when you squared,
it's going to be z over a zero cubed,
right?
When you square it,
everybody with me on that?
Okay?
So what that means is you're going to get units that are CSI cubed per unit
volume,
because remember a zero is a distance.
So a zero cube does a volume.
So it's going to get a number.
The nuclear charge is a number Z.
The atomic number is a number.
So it's got to get a number per unit volume,
which is the right units to have for probability density.
What is it per unit volume?
Okay?
So this is just the bit that,
that scales that right?
So that you get the right density in the right units.
Okay?
So Z,
so you can drop that out.
That's not something very fundamentally interesting.
Okay,
let's try making up a one s orbital.
Where do you start?
Can somebody tell me where to choose?
It's not hard.
They're labeled with red,
right?
If you want one s you choose the top one,
okay?
And uh,
now if you've done that and is one and uh,
uh,
l is zero.
So when you come to the next one,
uh,
l has to be zero.
Now am can be either zero a or one.
Oh No,
actually,
wait a second.
If it's one,
uh,
no.
If Al is zero,
then m has to be zero.
It says in the second column is everybody see that?
You see top,
it says if l is zero,
then m can be zero l m okay.
If l for ED,
for l for em,
hard me to be non zero
like here you have to have an l that's greater than than zero.
Okay,
so to get a solution,
if you,
if you chose a and one and l had to be zero,
because remember that's the only choice here you can't have a higher El,
then m is also going to be zero,
so you've got to take this times this times this.
Okay.
Now how complicated are those functions?
K Square root of two over two.
That's just the constant.
That's nothing function or one over the square root of two Pi.
Right?
Big Deal.
Why do you have these constants in there?
Why do you care what constant?
You multiply the wave function by
for what purpose?
Normalization for normalization,
right?
If you want to get abs,
but if all you want is the shape,
forget constants.
So what's the real working part of the one s wave function?
What's the part that varies?
We have here at the zoo for a zero to three halves.
Forget that to forget.
That's where two over to forget that.
In fact the twos when cancel square to to here would cancel that square to two.
So it's one over the square root of Pi Times this time.
Swat
either the minus row over to,
that's the real working part of it,
right?
When you square it,
what are you going to get from e to the minus row over to
what's either the minus row over two squared?
Yeah,
Alex e to the minus row.
Okay.
So the,
the,
the probability density is going to be either the minus row times of constant.
Okay.
So here we got it.
It's a constant times,
either the minus row over to when we square it,
it's e to the minus row.
Now,
uh,
there's something interesting.
There are two things that are interesting here.
One,
we wanted to get a function of r theta and fee,
but we don't have our in it,
right?
We have row instead.
Why does,
why do we substitute are by row.
There's a good reason for that.
Row is defined,
which is indeed the Greek version of R is row.
Okay.
It's defined as our time's a constant.
The constant is twice the atomic number divided by n the quantum level n times
that distance a zero.
And why do you do it that way?
It's because if you do it that way,
then the same,
the same row works no matter what the nuclear charges and no matter what the ATO
what n is.
So you get the same.
So it makes the table very compact,
right?
Because he use the same thing no matter what Adam you're dealing with.
Right.
If you,
if you work in units of row rather than our that is scale are to take into
account the fact that you can have various nuclear charges.
Okay.
Allows using the same e to the minus row over to for any nuclear charge,Z and
any end.
And notice every one of these has either the minus row over to on it.
Now why does that make sense?
Why is it no surprise that these things have eaten the minus our,
have we ever seen that before?
Even the minus X is a as a wave function.
What kind of wave functions?
What wonder what does that mean?
When you have e to the minus R,
that's a constant negative potential.
Kinetic energy,
constant negative,
kinetic energy,
which is going to be the situation for any nucleus and an electron.
Once the electron gets pretty far away,
the energy stops changing,
right?
So the potential energy is constant.
The kinetic energy is constant,
right?
If the electron is bound to the nucleus,
that means it can't just fly off to infinity,
right?
So it's below the the ultimate potential energy.
Then you have constant negative kinetic energy when you're far from the nucleus,
right?
So either the minus row,
so it doesn't surprise you that every one of these has either the minus row in
it.
Okay?
Now,
let's just look at this scaling quickly.
Okay,
so here's either the minus row and row as a function of row,
okay?
Now suppose so.
So we can rearrange this are is is that if we want to try,
if we want to make a new plot,
which has the horizontal axis being are being distance instead of row,
okay?
Now,
so our effort for a hydrogen atom,
the one s orbital of a hydrogen atom is 0.53 on.
So n is one a zero is half an on strum,
Z is one.
So it's 0.53 over two times row.
So we could just put a new scale on there.
So here's,
here's half an Oxfam for a hydrogen.
Here's one oxygen for a hydrogen.
Everybody with me on this?
So far,
how I did that,
right?
I just went through and found out for any given row here that I already had one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
either the minus row for any given row.
What would the RB,
if I were talking about a hydrogen atom and I just put a new scale on there.
Now,
if I were talking about a carbon atom,
which as a nuclear charge of plus six,
right then,
then this numberZ is going to be much bigger.
It's going to be six times as big.
What effect will that have on the scale?
So suppose where,
suppose we're at,
uh,
at uh,
five four row,
right?
Instead of dividing by one for z here,
I'm going to be divided by six,
so I'm going to get much shorter distances.
Real distances rather than our rather than row,
I mean,
right.
Does that surprise you that the function is going to squash in if I have a plus
six nuclear charge,
is it surprise you or not?
It's what you expect.
A bigger charge is going to suck the electrons in more.
Okay.
So if I do it for carbon,
I get 0.53 over 12 instead of 0.5,
three over two and the scale is going to look like that instead of this being
0.5 here for hydrogen,
it's 0.1,
right?
So then if I squash it in so that they're on the same scale,
those are different Ostrom scales for carbon and hydrogen.
If I make them the same scale,
the bigger nuclear charge sucks.
The one s function by a factor of six and it looks like that.
But now of course,
if I want the real,
the normalized function,
it's got to be higher,
right?
So the,
the total area is the same.
I have the squared function here,
either the minus row,
I remember it was the way functional needs in my eyes.
Roll rover to the density is e to the minus row to get the same thing.
I'm going to have to multiply that by six.
So it's going to look like that.
So that's how the radial distribution probability density distribution looks
different for a one electron.
Adam with a plus with a plus one or a plus six nuclear charge carbon holds its
core electrons in much more tightly than hydrogen does.
No big surprise there.
Okay.
Uh,
so here's something to think about.
what,
what would,
how would it differ if instead of talking about the one s orbital of carbon,
I was talking about the two s orbital of carbon.
Right now roe is going to be different and here instead of one is going to be
too.
So it's going to change the scale by a factor of two.
So that two,
it two s are further out.
Okay.
So for Wednesday,
I want you to do these problems.
You can do them in groups if you want to,
uh,
some,
some about Claude knee figures and then some things about,
uh,
energy and some atomic orbital problems.
Now we already looked at the,
at the one s let's,
let's look at some other,
uh,
atomic orbitals.
Incidentally,
this function,
the culotte big function is simpler in three dimensions than it is in one
dimension.
It was that complicated thing in one dimension,
you remember that had the cusp on it.
It was a really complicated function,
but it's really simple in three dimensions.
It's just exponential in our,
uh,
how does it vary with Theta as you come down from the access?
How does the wave function?
Very the one s what does it say?
How does it depend on theta?
Does it?
How does it depend on fee?
It doesn't.
So what shape does it have?
It sparingly symmetric.
It depends only on r and the s and the dependence on our is as easy as pie.
It's just either the minus R or road.
Depends on what units you measure are in.
Okay,
now let's look at two s.
Now tell me what to do.
How do I write a two s functions from this table?
First I have to choose the appetizer.
Where do I go?
Second one down is two s okay,
so I take this one and now two s that means l is zero,
right?
So where do I go?
What direction do I go here?
Right?
And then what direction do I go straight across to as m is zero.
Okay,
so here's there's two s,
multiply those together.
Now what's interesting,
there are a bunch of constants that are going to get me it make it normalized.
So that's a constant,
that's a constant,
just like they were before.
This is a constant,
that's a constant.
But this part is interesting to minus row
times e to the minus row over two.
That's the function that we're interested in.
Two minus row times e to the minus row over to that has an interesting thing.
What happens when row has the value to
it has the,
even the minus row over two that's just decay.
All of them have that,
but how about the two minus row?
That gives an interesting thing.
What happened?
What is,
what's its value when row is to zero?
So there's a node.
What shape is the node?
Is it a point?
Is it alive?
Is it a wiggly thing?
It's a sphere.
It's fairly symmetric.
Again,
so there's a spherical node,
so inside at a node,
the wave function changes sign.
So inside it's one side outside,
it's the opposite side.
Okay.
Now how about a two PZ orbital.
So where are we going to go to p?
We'll start with this and for Pz we do this one and fuzzy.
We do this one.
So it's this times,
this times this.
I think I have that circled here.
Let's see.
Yeah,
this is this one.
Interesting.
Now is this one interesting?
What part of it's interesting.
Coast Theta is interesting,
right?
That's real variation.
And what part's interesting here?
It's row times e to the minus row over to,
okay,
so it's some constant times,
row times the cosine theta types,
e to the minus row over to you always have the minus rover to forget.
That just means that decays as you go out.
Now row times co-signed a theta.
What does that mean?
Row,
which is this distance times the coast sine of theta.
What is that
Russel?
It's z.
So why can simplify this a lot?
If I mix my metaphors between polar and and uh,
and Cartesian coordinates,
it's z times either the minus row over two,
that's the two p orbital.
Now can you guess what the two Px in the two P y look like?
Can somebody guess the two p?
Why Josh
or replace what
replaced Z with x?
You get the two px orbital that replaces Z with why you get the two p.
Why orbital?
Pretty straightforward functions.
Now how about you've seen pictures of P orbitals?
What?
It's interesting now that you know what the functions look like.
It's interesting to go back to the pictures you've seen and see what they mean.
How do they relate to the,
to the actual formula.
So you could plot the member.
It's,
it's,
it's three parts and our function of Theta function,
a family function.
We could look at each of those functions separately if we wanted to.
Okay.
We've been talking about the r function,
how it would behave,
but how would the theta function behave in this co-signed data?
So we'll do a polar plot that shows the value of cosine theta as a function of
Feta.
Everybody with me?
Okay,
so what is it when Theta is zero,
what's Co sine of Theta One?
Okay,
so there it is and we'll put a point there.
now let's go to the plus and minus 30 degrees.
Co-Sign is 0.86 and we'll put points there.
And let's go to 45 degrees.
It's the square root of 2.7 squared.
Square root of a half 0.71 put points there.
Uh,
at 60 degrees,
it's a half put points there.
What is it?
If it's zero,
if it's a 90 degrees,
pardon me,
it was 90 degrees.
Coastline is zero.
So we got a point at the origin,
right?
So you can see what the shape is,
what if you go the other direction,
what if you go beyond 90 degrees?
What does happens to co sign
changes side?
So you've got another circle that's negative on the other side.
So there's a p orbital,
but I'm not showing the whole p orbital,
right?
I'm just showing the and how the angular part varies.
So you've seen pictures like that of p orbitals,
which is the theta function.
Or I could square it in order to look at probability density as a function of
theta,
right?
And it would look like that.
So you've seen pictures more or less like that?
Or I could make a picture like that,
which is uh,
a contour plot showing how big it is on a slice through the nucleus,
right?
So it's road times,
either the minus row over two times,
cosine theta.
That multiplied by a constant is the wave function.
Okay?
So you can see it's positive up the top negative at the bottom.
And let's look at,
look at it a little bit.
So and notice it doesn't depend on fee,
the angle of rotation around here.
So we can take that picture and rotate it to give a three dimensional dumbbell.
Okay,
we're just looking at one slice here in order to be explicit,
okay?
Now,
so there's a certain point there that has a certain row and a certain theta and
therefore it has a certain value.
Now let's find the maximum from that of that function.
Okay,
so first it depends on cosigned theta,
what we'll say to be in order for this to be maximum
zero.
So it has to be along the axis.
Okay?
Now,
so theta has to be equal to zero.
Okay?
Now how do we find where it's going to be maximum?
With respect to row,
we take the derivative with respect to row,
set it equal to zero.
So that's this or simplified that or simplified that roe equals two.
So there's the maximum and we could find what the problem,
if we put the constants in,
we could find the true probability density anywhere,
right?
Just plug in theta,
plug in row and square it,
multiply it by the constant.
That's the electron density at any given at the point you're talking about now.
Or You could have a computer do it for you.
And that's where we're indebted to Dean Dowager,
who's a physicist.
You went to Occidental College and actually wrote this program.
Volley was there,
but then he got a phd at Ucla in physics and he wrote this for physicists,
but we'll use it.
Okay,
here's a picture of Dean Dowager.
He also juggles and here's a picture of him at an apple developer conference and
he's juggling the guy on the left there.
He also drops one of the pins.
He's not perfect.
Okay.
So this is his program.
He's at the apple developer conference.
It's all works only on an apple.
So if you don't have an apple borrow somebodies apple to look at the program
because it's really fun.
This is the screen of the program.
And,
uh,
I don't have time to take you through it now,
but you should try it.
So look at the PowerPoint at this and the next few slides,
the learn what all the different information is that's being given here and the
kinds of questions you can ask.
There's a one s orbital,
right?
And it's as if the thing were really the electron.
We're really colored and it's a picture of how it would actually look if you
could see electron density,
but all of course he's done is use fancy computer graphics to plot the square of
the wave function.
Right.
And it's a really nice program.
We'll talk about this a little more next time.